Would you ever confess to a crime you didn't commit? Most people answer that question with a resounding no. Yet, according to the Innocence Project, almost 30% of wrongful conviction cases overturned by DNA testing involved a false confession. So why do people, seemingly of sound mind, implicate themselves? The answers may surprise you, but they shouldn't. In this episode, we speak with a psychologist about how law enforcement
你是否曾向一个自己并未犯下的罪行认罪？大多数人的回答都是坚决的“不”。然而，根据“无罪计划”（Innocence Project），通过DNA检测被平反的冤假错案中，近30%都包含虚假口供。那么，为什么看似神志清醒的人会自证其罪呢？答案可能会让你感到意外，但也理所当然。在本期节目中，我们邀请了一位心理学家，探讨执法人员
current policies, and our own sense of justice can lead to false confessions. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Saul Kasson is a distinguished professor of psychology at John Jay College of Criminal Justice. He has pioneered the scientific study of false confessions, and his research has been integral in preventing wrongful convictions and understanding why innocent people are targeted for interrogation, why they confess and the effect of this evidence on judges and juries. Welcome, Dr. Casson. Thank you.
当前的政策以及我们自身的正义感是如何导致虚假口供的。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton），这里是《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology）。索尔·卡森（Saul Kassin）是约翰杰伊刑事司法学院（John Jay College of Criminal Justice）的杰出心理学教授。他是虚假口供科学研究的先驱，其研究对于防止冤假错案、理解无辜者为何成为审讯目标、他们为何认罪以及此类证据对法官和陪审团的影响起到了不可或缺的作用。欢迎你，卡森博士。谢谢。
Good to be here. Let's start right off the bat with the most obvious question. I think people have about false confessions. Why would anyone confess to something they didn't do? Do we understand the psychology of why this happens, especially in something like a murder investigation? Right. You know, it's interesting.
很高兴来到这里。我们直接从大家对虚假口供最常提出的、最明显的问题开始吧。为什么会有人承认自己没有做过的事？我们是否理解为什么会发生这种情况的心理机制，尤其是在谋杀案调查中？没错。你知道，这很有趣。
That is the most interesting first question because when I ask people, would that be something you would ever do? The answer unanimously and strongly is no. nobody imagines they would ever do it short of having a gun to their head. The very short answer is that everybody has a breaking point, but it's a little bit more complex than that. It turns out there are three types of false confessions, and there are three different storylines as to why an individual would confess to something they didn't do. One is there is a category of false confessions known as voluntary false confessions.
这是最有趣的一个最初的问题，因为当我问别人“你会做这种事吗”时，大家的回答异口同声且非常坚决——“不会”。没有人会想象自己会做出这种事，除非被人拿枪指着头。最简短的回答是：每个人都有崩溃的临界点，但情况要稍微复杂一些。事实证明，虚假口供分为三类，对于个人为什么会承认自己未曾做过的事，也有三种不同的剧情。其中一类虚假口供被称为自愿虚假口供。
These are cases, and it often happens in high. profile cases that are in the news where people come out of the woodwork and volunteer confessions to crime the crimes that are in the news that they didn't commit. Kind of the poster child instance of that in history is when Charles Lindbergh's infant son was kidnapped in 1932, 200 people volunteered confessions and all of them were false. You see that again in high profile cases. Sometimes people volunteer confessions because they're seeking attention. Sometimes they're looking actually to protect somebody else who is the culprit. And sometimes it reflects some degree of delusion and it reflects on their mental health. Honestly, I don't see the voluntary
这些案件通常发生在新闻中备受瞩目的重大案件中，当时总会有人主动跑来，自愿为新闻中报道的他们并未犯下的罪行认罪。历史上最具代表性的例子就是在1932年查尔斯·林德伯格（Charles Lindbergh）的幼子被绑架时，有200人主动招供，而所有这些口供都是假的。你在高调的案件中总能再次看到这种现象。有时人们自愿认罪是因为他们在博取关注。有时他们实际上是为了保护真正的罪魁祸首。还有时，这在一定程度上反映了某种妄想，折射出他们的心理健康状况。老实说，我不认为自愿
false confessions while they happen and happen with some degree of regularity and always have. I don't see them as a particular problem for the criminal justice system. I think it's interesting that when somebody volunteers a confession to police, police typically react with some degree of skepticism. And they ask the question. And so they say, well, you say you committed this murder, prove it. What do you know about the crime? And if the individual who's offering to admit guilt can't also provide details about the crime
虚假口供——尽管它们确实会发生，并且具有一定规律性，过去也一直存在——是刑事司法系统的一个特大问题。我觉得很有意思的是，当有人主动向警方坦白时，警方通常会持一定程度的怀疑态度。他们会提出质疑。所以他们会说：“好吧，你说你犯了这起谋杀案，证明给我们看。关于这起犯罪你都知道些什么？”如果这个主动认罪的人无法提供与警方所掌握的、准确的案情细节
that are accurate as known to the police, then the police don't follow that case. And so those voluntary false confessions don't tend to enter the criminal justice system as problematic. The problematic are the next two types. And these are the types of false confessions that arise from police interrogations. These are innocent people who, when asked about the crime, deny any involvement, and then they are subject to a process of interrogation. And it is as a result of that process of interrogation that a confession,
相符的信息，警方就不会推进该案。因此，这类自愿虚假口供往往不会作为严重问题进入刑事司法系统。真正成问题的是接下来这两种。这些是由警方审讯引发的虚假口供。这些都是无辜的人，当被问及罪行时，他们否认任何牵连，随后他们便经受了一轮审讯过程。正是由于这一审讯过程，才产生了一份口供，
that a confession is produced. So these are categories of police-induced false confessions. The way in which the two categories differ is the most common form is you bring a person in who denies involvement, who is now subject to a harrowing and relentless interrogation. Promises may be made, threats may be made, promises implied, threats implied, stress level is increased. They're isolated, they're away from anybody who, familiar and essentially, to make a long story short, everybody has a breaking point. And these are
一份虚假口供。因此，这些属于警方诱导的虚假口供类别。这两种类别的区别在于，最常见的一种形式是：你把一个否认涉案的人带进来，此人随后遭受了一场痛苦且毫不留情的审讯。可能会有许诺，也可能会有威胁；有明示的承诺，也有暗示的承诺；有明示的威胁，也有暗示的威胁；压力水平不断上升。他们被孤立，远离任何熟悉的人。简而言之，每个人都有崩溃的临界点。这些都是
cases where individuals who are innocent, who know they're innocent, break down and confess in order to extract themselves from a very bad situation. They do what psychologists have known people to do in stressful decision-making situations, which is they maximize their opportunity to get themselves out of that situation. And as for the long-term consequence, well, I'll worry about that when the time comes. They're just not thinking clearly anymore. Classic, recent, historic, I think example, the Central Park Five. There was a case where five false confessions were produced in a single investigation. And every one of those 14, 15, and 16-year-old boys who confessed later said, I knew I didn't do it. I thought I was helping myself out by cooperating.
那些无辜的、深知自己清白的个人为了摆脱极其糟糕的处境而崩溃并招供的案件。他们做出了心理学上已知人们在压力重重的决策情境下会做的事，那就是最大化他们摆脱那种处境的机会。至于长期的后果，好吧，等时候到了我再去操心。他们的大脑已经无法清晰思考了。一个经典、近期且具历史意义的例子，我认为就是“中央公园五人组”（Central Park Five）。那是一个在单一调查中产生五份虚假口供的案件。每一个当时14、15和16岁、后来招供的男孩都说：“我知道我没干。我以为通过配合能帮自己脱身。”
And so that is, I think, the most common type of false confession. innocent person, broken down, and the metric of the fact that these are what we call compliant false confessions. That is, they confess as an act of compliance while privately remaining knowledgeable that they're innocent. The metric of that is as soon as the pressure of the situation is lifted, they recant the confession. But it's too late. It doesn't matter. Nobody pays attention to the recant. Nobody trusts the recantation as much as they do the confession. The third type of false confession is in some ways, when I first discover this, we wrote about this, Larry Reitzman and I wrote about this in 1985, was the most vexing because there wasn't a psychology in place yet to explain it.
所以，我认为这是最常见的一种虚假口供：无辜的人精神崩溃，而这种现象的衡量标准就是我们所说的顺从型虚假口供。也就是说，他们招供只是一种顺从的行为，但在私下里仍然坚信自己是无辜的。这种现象的衡量标准在于，一旦情况带来的压力解除，他们就会翻供。但为时已晚。这已经不重要了。没有人会去注意翻供。比起口供，没有人会相信翻供。第三种虚假口供在某些方面——当我最初发现这一点时，我和拉里·赖茨曼（Larry Wrightsman）在1985年撰文探讨过——是最令人头疼的，因为当时还没有相应的心理学理论来解释它。
We called it internalized false confessions. These are instances where an innocent person denying any involvement is put through a series of interrogation tactics and ultimately comes out not only willing to sign a confession as an act of compliance, but they come to internalize the belief in their own guilt. They come to believe they have committed this crime. Now that is a different type of process and a different story than what happens in the compliant false confessions. But what happens in internalization is this.
我们称之为内化型虚假口供。这些情况是指，一个否认任何涉案行为的无辜之人经历了一系列审讯战术，最终不仅愿意作为一种顺从行为签署认罪书，而且开始内化对自己有罪的信念。他们开始相信自己确实犯下了罪行。这与顺从型虚假口供发生的过程和故事截然不同。而内化过程中发生的事情是这样的。
What's fascinating about them, I've seen about a dozen of them firsthand, where we can actually watch the process. And what's fascinating is the names change, the dates change, the places change. the place has changed. The script is almost always about the same. And the script is this. A suspect is brought in who is vulnerable to manipulation. And when I say vulnerable, I mean either they are vulnerable dispositionally. They may be mentally, intellectually impaired. They may be young.
最迷人的是，我亲眼目睹过大约十起这样的案件，我们能够亲眼目睹这个过程。迷人之处在于：名字变了，日期变了，地点变了。地点变了，剧本却几乎总是雷同的。剧本是这样的：一个容易受到操纵的嫌疑人被带了进来。当我说的“易受操纵”时，我的意思是他们可能在性格上就很脆弱。他们可能存在心理或智力上的缺陷。他们可能年纪很小。
They may be 12, 13, 14, 16 years old. They may have been deprived of sleep and therefore rendered vulnerable to manipulation, they may be under so much stress or traumatized because a loved one had just been found murdered. In fact, they're being accused of that murder. Whatever it is, they are vulnerable. They're in a stressful state of mind. And as a result of the process of interrogation, they are continuing to deny involvement. And then the detective doing the interrogating launches into a series of tactics that shocks most Americans to know is lawful. They start to lie to the suspect about the evidence. So, for example, Marty Tankliff, 17 years old, young 17 years old, wakes up one morning in 1990,
他们可能只有12、13、14、16岁。他们可能被剥夺了睡眠，从而变得容易受到操纵；他们可能承受着巨大的压力，或者因为挚爱刚刚被谋杀而受到创伤。事实上，他们正被指控犯下了那起谋杀案。无论是什么原因，他们都很脆弱。他们处于精神压力巨大的状态中。由于审讯过程，他们继续否认涉案。接着，负责审讯的警探开始实施一系列让大多数美国人感到震惊（并意识到这是合法的）的战术。他们开始就证据对嫌疑人撒谎。例如，马蒂·唐克利夫（Marty Tankleff），17岁，一个还很年轻的17岁少年，在1990年的一天早晨醒来，
and he finds lights are on all over the house. He finds his parents have been bludgeoned. His mother is dead in a pool of blood. He runs to his father's study and sees him gurgling, still alive but unconscious, also surrounded by blood. He calls the police, the police come, they identify him for no good reason as the suspect. And while his family is off at the emergency room in a hospital with his father, and he wants to be there and keep saying, I'd like to be with my family, not until we're done here, not until we're done here. So he's in an agitated, traumatized state. the detective starts to launch into a series of lies about the evidence.
他发现全屋的灯都亮着。他发现自己的父母遭到了重击殴打。他的母亲倒在血泊中死亡。他跑进父亲的书房，看到父亲在咯咯作响，虽然还活着但已失去意识，周围也全是血。他报警了。警察来了，在没有充分理由的情况下将他确定为嫌疑人。当时他的家人正和他的父亲一起前往医院的急诊室，而他希望去那里并一直说“我想和我的家人在一起”，警方却说“不行，等我们这里搞定再说，等我们这里搞定再说”。因此，他处于一种激动、受创的状态中，
He says, Marty, you said you had nothing to do with this. How does that explain the fact that your hair was found in your mother's grasp? And Marty said, well, and that wasn't true. Marty said, well, I don't know how that could be possible. And then he asked, it looks like you use the shower this morning. And Marty said, no, I didn't. Because they couldn't explain the fact that there are two bloody murder scenes in this house. And Marty's clean.
警探开始就证据抛出一系列谎言。他说：“马蒂，你说你跟这事没关。那怎么解释在你母亲手中发现了你的头发这一事实呢？”马蒂说：“嗯……”而那其实并不是真的。马蒂说：“嗯，我不知道这怎么可能。”接着警探问：“看起来你今天早上冲过澡了。”马蒂说：“没有，我没有。”因为他们无法解释这栋房子里有两个血腥的谋杀现场，而马蒂身上却很干净的事实。
They arrive at the scene and he's clean. They convinced him that they did a humidity test on the shower in his bedroom and that it proved that the shower had been used that morning. That was a lie. So now Marty's starting to wonder what the truth is and he's getting confused and disoriented. Then the detective gets up and physically leaves the room and leaves Marty in there with his partner. He comes back in, he says, Marty, I've got good news and bad news. The good news is I just contacted the hospital. your father has regained consciousness.
他们赶到现场时，他身上是干净的。他们说服了他，说他们对他的卧室淋浴间进行了湿度测试，证明那天早上淋浴间被使用过。那是个谎言。于是马蒂开始怀疑什么是真理，并变得困惑和迷失方向。接着，警探起身离开了房间，把马蒂留给他的搭档。他回来后说：“马蒂，我有个好消息和一个坏消息。好消息是，我刚联系了医院，你父亲已经恢复意识了。”
The bad news is he said you did this. Oh my gosh. Wow. And that was a lie. And Marty said, my father never lies. If he said I did this, then I must have done this. That is the pattern that you see. Vulnerable suspect, dispositionally or rendered vulnerable, lied to about the evidence,
“坏消息是，他说这事是你干的。”“哦，天哪。哇。”而那是个谎言。马蒂说：“我父亲从不撒谎。如果他说是我干的，那一定是我干的。”这就是你所看到的模式：脆弱的嫌疑人（生性脆弱或被诱导变得脆弱），被欺骗了证据，
starting to get confused about reality. In some cases, the degree of internalization ends with they no longer can attest to their own innocence. They're confused. In some cases, it becomes a full-blown belief that they committed this crime and a search for the details as to how they did it. And so what happens is they eventually confess by using words like, I guess I did it, I guess I must have done it. It looks like I could always that kind of tentative, fragmentary language. And then ultimately they produce a fuller confession filled with the kinds of details that were handed to them through the process of interrogation. So if you're an observer in court and all you're hearing is that final statement,
开始对现实产生困惑。在某些情况下，内化程度的结局是他们再也无法证明自己的清白。他们糊涂了。在某些情况下，这变成了一种根深蒂固的信念，即他们犯下了这起罪行，并开始寻找他们是如何犯下该罪行的细节。因此发生的情况是，他们最终使用了诸如“我想是我干的”、“我想我一定干过”、“看起来我好像总是……”这样试探性的、碎片化的语言来认罪。最后，他们炮制出一份更加完整的供词，里面充斥着通过审讯过程灌输给他们的各种细节。因此，如果你是法庭上的旁听者，而你所听到的全部只有那份最终的陈述，
there's no way you can get past it. And so that third category of false confessions, fascinating, you see it over and over again, again, not nearly as prevalent as the compliant false confessions, but it's a third storyline where the process of interrogation actually converts the beliefs and memories, and sometimes they actually confabulate memories of what they did and how they did it. What is the most common thing that you see in these interrogations that leads you to believe someone may not be telling the truth or is feeling intimidated? I think you've touched a little bit on this already, but I'm curious in some more examples.
你是绝对无法看清真相的。因此，这第三类虚假口供——令人着迷，你会一次又一次地看到它——虽然远不如顺从型虚假口供那么普遍，但它是第三种剧情：审讯过程实际上改变了他们的信念和记忆，有时他们甚至会虚构出关于自己做了什么以及如何做的记忆。在这些审讯中，你看到的最常见的迹象是什么，让你相信某人可能在说谎或者感到受到了恐吓？我想你之前已经稍微触及过这一点了，但我对更多的例子很感兴趣。
How are law enforcement officials contributing to these false confessions? They are contributing mightily to false confessions. And there's two things I should say about this. First, you imagine, imagine yourself sitting in a courtroom watching a videotaped confession. So the suspect has been brought to the point of giving a statement. And at that point, the videotape recorder is turned on and a statement is given, and that statement later is played in court. I can tell you as an empirical matter, we've done these studies. And certainly the wrongful convictions experiences of people who have been wrongfully convicted will attest,
执法人员是如何导致这些虚假口供的？他们对虚假口供有着巨大的推波助澜作用。对此我有两点要说。首先，你可以想象一下自己坐在法庭上观看录像供词的场景。嫌疑人已经被逼到了招供的地步。就在那时，录像机被打开，供词被给出，而这份供词随后在法庭上被播放。我可以从实证的角度告诉你，我们做过这些研究。当然，那些被错误定罪的人的经历也足以证明，
judges, juries, laypeople, they can't tell the difference between a true confession and a false confession just by watching the confession. I went into a prison outside of Boston with colleagues. We had prisoners on tape confessing to the crimes for which they were incarcerated, and then we asked each one to make up a confession to a crime he did not commit. People cannot tell the difference between those two sets of confessions. And the story of every false confession is not a story of what happened in the police interrogation room. It's a story of the fact that once that false confession was taken and recanted and the person pled not guilty and went to trial, in every instance, a prosecutor, a judge, a jury, and typically an appeals court, believed that
法官、陪审团、外行仅仅通过观看认罪过程，根本无法分辨真假供词的区别。我曾与同事一起进入波士顿郊外的一座监狱。我们让囚犯在录像中承认他们因其服刑的罪行，然后我们要求每个人编造一份他并未犯下的罪行的供词。人们根本无法分辨这两组供词的区别。每一个虚假口供的故事都不是关于警察审讯室内发生了什么的故事，而是关于这样一个事实：一旦这份虚假口供被录取、随后又被翻供，且当事人做出了无罪抗辩并走上审判庭时，在每一种情况下，检察官、法官、陪审团，通常还有上诉法院，都会相信那份
false confession. The second terrible subplot in these cases is not just that the false confession was taken. It's that all the safety nets we believe are built into the system fail. People believe false confessions. So first thing it's important to know is there's no way to identify what it is that law enforcement does simply by watching, that contributes simply by watching the final statement. That's why what's most important and whenever I clamor for reform and other psychologists in this area clamor for reform, the number one rule for reform is record the entire process. The minute they walk in to the road.
虚假口供。这些案件中第二个可怕的次要情节不仅在于虚假口供被录取了，还在于我们认为内置于系统中的所有安全网都失效了。人们相信虚假口供。因此，首先重要的是要明白，仅通过旁观执法人员在最终供词录制时的行为，是无法识别出究竟是什么因素导致了虚假口供。这就是为什么最重要的事情——每当我大声疾呼进行改革以及该领域的其他心理学家大声疾呼改革时——改革的第一条铁律就是：记录整个过程。从他们走进大门的那一分钟开始。
The minute they walk in. And in fact, you know, I'm sitting here right now in the District of Columbia. Metro Police, D.C. Metro Police went to the system years ago. They've got interview room set up. And as soon as somebody walks into the room, the motion activation system turns on the lights and turns on the camera. Simple as that. Every interaction is recorded. It's the only way that a judge and a jury can make a reasonable determination as to what happened.
从他们走进大门的那一分钟开始。事实上，你知道，我现在就坐在哥伦比亚特区。大都会警察局，华盛顿特区大都会警察局多年前就采用了这个系统。他们设置了审讯室。只要有人走进房间，运动激活系统就会自动开灯并开启摄像头。就这么简单。每一次互动都被记录下来。这是法官和陪审团对发生的事情做出合理裁决的唯一途径。
You can't know from listening to the final product. Now, why I keep saying judge and jury, the judge, almost always when a confessor recants and goes to trial, the judge ends up having to rule in a pretrial suppression hearing as to whether or not that confession was voluntary. Because by law, if the judge determines that it was not voluntary, then it should not be admissible into evidence. In the case is usually closed. So every judge has to rule on whether the confession was voluntary. Most times confessions are ruled voluntary. They go into trial, and then it's up to the jury to determine whether it's a credible confession.
从听最终的录音产品中你是无法知道这一点的。为什么我一直提到法官和陪审团呢？当供述者翻供并进入审判程序时，几乎在所有情况下，法官最终都必须在审前听证会上裁定该供述是否出于自愿。因为根据法律，如果法官裁定供述不是出于自愿，那么它就不应该被采纳为证据，案件通常也会随之结案。因此，每个法官都必须对供述是否自愿做出裁决。大多数情况下，供述都会被裁定为自愿的，案件随后进入审判程序，接着由陪审团来决定这是否是一个可信的供述。
I don't know how a judge is competent to determine voluntariness without watching the process. I don't know how a jury can know whether it's a good confession without watching the process. And the reason all of this can be so confusing is another, another empirical fact. When you look at analyses of real, known, proven false confessions, taken right out of the Innocence Project case files. Right. This is the one where they use DNA to...
我不知道法官在不观看整个审讯过程的情况下，凭什么有能力裁定自愿性；我也不知道陪审团在不观看过程的情况下，怎么能知道这是一个好的供述。所有这一切之所以会如此令人困惑，还有另一个实证事实。当你审视那些真实的、已知的、被证实的虚假供述的分析时，这些案例直接取自“无罪计划”的案卷。没错，就是那些他们利用DNA来进行……
Yes. Right. So these are DNA exonerated men and women who had confessed. So we know now that they're actually innocent and that the confessions were false. When you go back and look at those confessions, 95% of them contained facts about the case that were spot-on accurate with regard to the crime and that were not in the public domain. Facts that only the perpetrator could have known. The problem is the police knew those facts too.
是的，没错。所以这些都是通过DNA证明无罪但曾经招供的男女。因此我们现在知道他们其实是无辜的，而且那些供述是虚假的。当你回过头去查看那些供述时，其中95%的供述都包含了一些关于案件的细节，这些细节在犯罪事实方面准确无误，并且不在公共领域内，也就是只有作案者才知道的事实。问题是，警察也知道这些事实。
And somehow, advertently or inadvertently, those facts made their way into the final statement. So imagine a judge or a jury ruling on a confession, determining if this is a good confession. They're not just hearing an admission of guilt. They're hearing an admission of guilt, followed by a full narrative story. This is what I did. This is how I did it. This is who I was with. This is why I did it.
而且不知何故，有意或无意地，这些事实最终进入了最后的供述陈述中。因此，想象一下法官或陪审团在对供述进行裁决、判断这是否是一个好的供述时，他们听到的不仅仅是一句认罪的话。他们听到的是认罪，接着是一段完整的叙事故事：这是我做的，我是这么做的，我和谁在一起，我为什么这么做。
This is what I saw and heard along the way. And then my colleagues and I also content analyzed some known false confessions. They often contain physical reenactments, hand-drawn maps, apologies and expressions of remorse, Corey Wise of the Central Park Five, not only did he admit to taking part in the rape of a jogger, which he had nothing to do with, embedded in his statement, which was videotaped, was an apology. He said, this is my first rape and it's going to be my last. I'm never going to do this again. That's a false confession. That's the sight and sound of a false confession. There's no way a judge and a jury can know how to measure that without having heard the process
这是我在这一过程中看到和听到的。然后，我和我的同事们还对一些已知的虚假供述进行了内容分析。它们通常包含实物重构、手绘地图、道歉和悔恨的表现。“中央公园五人组”中的科里·怀斯不仅承认参与了一起对慢跑者的强奸案（而这与他毫无关系），而且在他被录像的陈述中还包含了一句道歉。他说：“这是我的第一次强奸，也将是我的最后一次。我再也不会这么做了。”这是一个虚假的供述，这就是虚假供述的表象。如果不了解产生这一供述的过程，法官和陪审团根本无法知道如何去衡量它。
that gave rise to it. Now, thankfully, 25 states require the recording of interrogations, at least in serious felony cases. How do you think psychological research can be used to help educate law enforcement on changing the way they conduct interrogations? Fascinating question. There are many ways in which psychologists have exerted influence over practice. One is, it is clear that many of the techniques that are used, and I should say there's not one technique for interrogation. There tends to be an American-style, confrontational-style set of techniques that are shaped around what the law permits, and those techniques are confrontational, meaning the goal is to accuse, right out of the gate,
现在，值得庆幸的是，有25个州要求对审讯进行录像，至少在重罪案件中是这样。你认为心理学研究可以如何用来帮助教育执法部门改变他们进行审讯的方式？这是一个非常吸引人的问题。心理学家对实践施加影响的方式有很多种。首先，很明显，所使用的许多技术——而且我应该说审讯并没有单一的技术。往往存在一套围绕法律允许的范围而形成的美国式、对抗式的技术，而这些技术是对抗性的，意味着其目标就是开门见山地进行指控，
accuse the suspect of having committed this crime. And, in fact, the opening salvo of an American-style interrogation is an accusation. is an accusation of guilt, and a refusal to accept denials. So when the subject denies that having any involvement post-accusation, typically what the American detective will do is call that person a liar, say, no, we know what happened, we want you to tell the truth. And the process then proceeds kind of relentlessly for some degree of time. I should say the average interrogation lasts for 30 to 60 minutes. But if you look at false confession cases, there's six hours, eight hours, ten hours, fourteen hours. And so this is this relentless process. Now, it starts with an accusation. Eventually what happens is the
指控嫌疑人犯下了这起罪行。事实上，美国式审讯的开场白就是一项指控，是对有罪的指控，并且拒绝接受否认。因此，当嫌疑人在被指控后否认有任何卷入时，美国侦探通常会做的是把这个人称为骗子，说“不，我们知道发生了什么，我们要你讲实话”。然后这个过程就会在一定程度上无休止地进行下去。我应该说，平均审讯持续30到60分钟，但如果你看看虚假供述的案件，就会发现有六小时、八小时、十小时、十四小时。所以这是一个无休止的过程。现在，它从指控开始。最终发生的事情是，
American interrogator fashions a set of tactics that are designed both to make it stressful to continue to deny and less stressful to continue to confess. Get it over with. I'm done with this process. Get it over with. And along the way, not only does the interrogator, implied that we have all sorts of evidence against you. Most countries do not allow their police to lie about the evidence. It makes the suspect feel overwhelmed, as if they have no choice, as if there's an error of inevitability. And so now you're looking for an expedient way out. Well, here comes the second set of tactics, which I have collectively used the term minimization to describe it. Minimization is, and you see this in every one of these cases,
美国审讯人员设计了一套策略，旨在让继续否认变得压力巨大，而继续招供则压力更小。“快点结束吧，我受够这个过程了，快点结束吧。”在这个过程中，审讯人员不仅暗示我们掌握了针对你的各种证据——大多数国家的警察不允许在证据上撒谎——这会让嫌疑人感到不知所措，仿佛他们别无选择，仿佛有一种不可避免的宿命感。因此，你现在正在寻找一条权宜之计的退路。好吧，这里迎来了第二套策略，我用“淡化”这个词来统称它。淡化就是，你在每一个这样的案件中都会看到这一点，
Minimization is, you know, I think you're a good person. I don't think you intended to do this. I don't think this was something you went in there intending to do. It's possible you may have had too much to drink. It's possible somebody put you up to it. You were under pressure. You were provoked. There are externalizations of blame, moral justification.
淡化就是，“你知道的，我认为你是个好人，我不认为你是故意要这么做的，我不认为这是你一开始就打算去做的事情。你可能是喝了太多酒，可能是有人怂恿你，你当时承受着压力，你受到了挑衅。”这些都是对责任的外部归因和道德辩护。
The implication is, you know what, I don't think this is such a big deal. So the crime and the implications of that crime are minimized. It is not a coincidence that every one of the Central Park five boys and their families who were present. When their interrogations had concluded and they were put under arrest, they were shocked. They all thought they were going home. The most common comment you hear when a microphone is put into the face of an exonerie who had confessed is, so why did you confess? The typical thing they say is because they wanted to go home.
其暗示的意思是，“你知道吗，我觉得这算不上什么大事。”因此，犯罪行为及其后果被淡化了。中央公园五人组中的每一个男孩以及当时在场的家属，在审讯结束并被戴上手铐逮捕时，都感到震惊，这绝非巧合。他们都以为自己要回家了。当把麦克风递到一个招供后被证明无罪的人面前时，你听到最常见的一句话就是：“那你当时为什么要招供？”他们通常的回答是：“因为他们想回家。”
I don't know if you're familiar with the case of Brendan Dassey from making a murderer, the Netflix documentary. Dassey was 16 years old. He gave a confession. Shortly after giving that confession, there is a jaw-dropping moment when he says, am I going to get back to school in time? I have a project due. He had no idea he was going to be under arrest and he'd never go home again.
我不知道你是否熟悉Netflix纪录片《制造杀人犯》中布伦丹·达西的案子。达西当时16岁。他作出了供述。在做出该供述后不久，发生了一个令人瞠目结舌的时刻，他说：“我能及时赶回学校吗？我有一个作业要交。”他根本不知道自己将被逮捕，而且再也无法回家了。
And that tells you what kind of interrogation tactics were used. Minimization tactics are the final. way to take a subject who has been broken down, led to believe there's no way out, but if you cooperate with us, we think this is no big deal. Again, as an empirical matter, we've done these studies. When people hear minimization tactics, the take-home message that they infer when we ask them is leniency. This person will not be treated with a harsh punishment. And so that's the American-style interrogation. But there are others. In Europe, there is a a sweeping set of reforms. You ask, can psychology make change? Psychology has already made
这告诉你当时使用的是什么样的审讯方式。淡化策略是最后的方法，用来对待一个已经被瓦解、被引导相信已经无路可走的嫌疑人，但如果你与我们合作，我们认为这算不上什么大事。同样，从实证角度来看，我们做过这些研究。当人们听到淡化策略时，他们推断出的核心信息是宽大处理。这个人不会受到严厉的惩罚。这就是美国式的审讯。但还有其他的。在欧洲，有一系列深刻的改革。你问心理学能带来改变吗？心理学已经带来了
change. We have contributed to the fact that 25 states now record interrogations. In Europe, there is a sweeping reform that started in the United Kingdom, started in England, and that reform is to move away from the confrontational style investigation to what they call investigative interviewing, where the goal is to gather information, to figure out what happened, to determine whether or not this person has information, secondarily to solve the crime by confession. In England, they went to a new model as a result of some false confession cases in the 1980s, and as a result of reforming their form of interoper, moving from the kind of interrogation that we see in the U.S. to investigative interviewing, they have reported no change in their ability to close
改变。我们促成了现在有25个州对审讯进行录像这一事实。在欧洲，有一场始于英国、始于英格兰的深刻改革，这项改革是从对抗式调查转向他们所称的“调查性讯问”，其目标是收集信息、弄清发生了什么、确定这个人是否掌握信息，其次才是通过供述来破案。在英格兰，由于20世纪80年代的一些虚假供述案件，他们转向了一种新模式；由于改革了讯问形式，从我们在美国看到的这种审讯转向调查性讯问，他们报告说，他们破案的能力没有变化，获得供述的能力也没有变化，而且他们不再看到过去常常见到的那种虚假供述激增的现象。
cases, no change in their ability to get confessions, and they're no longer seeing this rash of false confession cases they used to report. Unlike in the United States, there has been a concerted effort to bring psychologists and practitioners together to create this new model. Here, there is a greater amount of resistance to moving in that direction. And that is why, at least as a backup, if you can't reform the process of interrogation, at the very least, you can make it transparent so that judges and juries and prosecutors can see what happened. The way everybody saw Brendan Dassey's interrogation taken at a time when the state of Wisconsin required the recording of interrogation, there was a public outcry when Netflix showed that documentary because people
与美国不同的是，这里有一致的努力将心理学家和实践者聚集在一起创造这种新模式。在这里，向这个方向发展的阻力更大。这就是为什么，至少作为一个备份，如果你不能改革审讯过程，至少你可以让它变得透明，以便法官、陪审团和检察官能够看到发生了什么。就像每个人在威斯康星州要求录像的时候看到布伦丹·达西的审讯一样，当Netflix播放那部纪录片时，公众群情激愤，因为人们
got to see the process, not just the final outcome. You've also studied quite a bit about why people waived their protections like Miranda rights. You have the right to remain silent. I'm interested in an experiment you did that was published in the journal law and human behavior where you had people pretend they were either guilty or innocent. This is like a mock theft of $100. Innocent people signed their Miranda waiver twice as often as guilty suspects. Why would they do that? Obviously, this wasn't a real crime, but what does this tell you about why people agree to talk even if they're innocent? How can this harm them in actual criminal investigations? This was an important topic, in part because I had spent a good amount of
得以看到整个过程，而不仅仅是最终结果。你还对人们为什么会放弃诸如米兰达权利之类的保护进行了深入研究。“你有权保持沉默。”我对你做的一项发表在《法律与人类行为》杂志上的实验很感兴趣，在这个实验中，你让人们假装自己是有罪的或是无辜的。这就像是一场模拟偷窃100美元的实验。无辜的人签署米兰达权利放弃书的频率是犯罪嫌疑人的两倍。他们为什么会这样做？显然，这不是一场真正的犯罪，但这说明了人们为什么会同意说话，即使他们是无辜的？这在实际刑事调查中会如何伤害他们？这是一个重要的话题，部分原因是我花了很多时间
time. I occasionally work as a consultant or an expert witness on cases involving false confessions. And I talk to those who had given false confessions. And one signal that came through loud and clear, because, you know, what they all have in common is they all gave false confessions, but they have something else in common. They all waive their Miranda rights. We're handed one means of protecting ourselves. And that is at any moment we can clam up and say we want a lawyer. We don't have to talk. We don't have to put ourselves through this hideous process. And so I asked them why. And it's fascinating. They all give you exactly the same answer in almost the same words. Why didn't you get a lawyer? Why didn't need a lawyer? Well, why didn't you need a lawyer? Well,
有时我会作为顾问或专家证人参与涉及虚假供述的案件。我与那些作过虚假供述的人交谈过。有一个信号非常清晰地传递出来，因为，你知道，他们共同的特点是都作出了虚假供述，但他们还有另一个共同点：他们都放弃了米兰达权利。我们手里有一种保护自己的手段，那就是在任何时刻我们都可以闭嘴并要求找一个律师。我们不必说话。我们不必让自己经受这个可怕的过程。所以我问他们为什么。结果很吸引人。他们给你的答案完全一样，几乎用的是同样的词。“你为什么不找个律师？”“为什么需要律师？”“好吧，你为什么不需要律师？”“嗯，
I didn't do anything wrong. They had this naive belief in the power of their innocence to prevail. The idea came to me because there had been data showing that Miranda waiver rates are very high. The police worried in 1966 when the U.S. Supreme Court forced them to read people their rights and get a waiver of those rights before they can interrogate them, they worried that nobody will ever talk to us again. That hasn't happened. 80 percent, roughly 75 to 80 percent of suspects waive their Miranda rights. And that's a statistic you find in this country and elsewhere where comparable rules are in place. And so you ask yourself the question, why?
我没做错任何事。”他们对自己的清白能够占上风抱有一种天真的信念。这个想法之所以来到我脑海中，是因为曾有数据显示米兰达权利放弃率非常高。1966年，当美国最高法院强迫警察在审讯前向人们宣读权利并获得放弃这些权利的声明时，警察曾担心以后再也不会有人跟我们说话了。这种情况并没有发生。大约80%（大约75%到80%）的嫌疑人都放弃了米兰达权利。这是你在美国以及其他实行类似规则的地方都能发现的一个统计数据。所以你会问自己一个问题：为什么？
And then you look more carefully at those data, and you find that people who've never been in trouble before, people who don't have a history with the criminal justice system. And therefore, people just as a base rate matter more likely to be innocent are much more likely to waive their rights. So based on those observations and my conversations with the wrongfully convicted, we brought that into the laboratory. I say this because this is not a mere laboratory phenomenon. The idea for it came from the real world. So now we bring it into the laboratory, and we have people go through the motions of stealing or not stealing $100. They know it's not real, but they are then put into the laboratory interrogation room and confronted with the detective who walks in, introduces himself as Detective McCarthy,
然后你更仔细地查看这些数据，你会发现那些从未惹过麻烦的人，那些没有刑事司法系统历史的人——因此，根据基本比例，这些人更有可能是无辜的——反而更有可能放弃他们的权利。基于这些观察以及我与被冤枉者的对话，我们把这一点带入了实验室。我之所以这么说，是因为这不仅仅是一个实验室现象，它的想法来源于现实世界。所以现在我们把它带入实验室，让人们经历偷窃或不偷窃100美元的过程。他们知道这不是真的，但随后他们被带入实验室审讯室，面对走进来并自我介绍为麦卡锡警探的侦探，
has either we actually vary whether his demeanor is hostile and close-minded, or whether he seems open and willing to. to hear their story. They are all incentivized to make themselves appear innocent. And the first thing he does is read them their rights and look to see whether they're willing to sign the waiver. And by a large margin of 81% to 36%, those who had nothing to hide, those whose accounts of their whereabouts and what they did would be truthful, 81% of them waive their rights compared to only 36% of them who actually had committed the mock crime. And they told us exactly what the wrongfully convicted say. Well, I didn't do anything wrong. He'll see that. Two explanations I had for what was happening here, and they're kind of related. One is people have a belief in a just world.
侦探的表现要么是敌对和封闭的，要么看起来是开放且愿意倾听他们的故事的。他们所有人都被激励着让自己看起来是清白的。他做的第一件事就是宣读他们的权利，并查看他们是否愿意签署放弃书。结果显示，以81%对36%的巨大差距，那些没有什么可隐瞒的人、那些关于他们的行踪和所作所为的陈述是真实的人中，有81%的人放弃了权利，而真正犯下模拟罪行的人中只有36%的人放弃了权利。他们告诉我们的完全是那些被冤枉的人所说的话：“嗯，我没做错什么，他会看出来的。”我对这里发生的事情有两个解释，而且它们有点相关。一是人们对公正世界的信仰。
Now, we know that. There is research and psychology on the belief in a just world. People tend to believe that the world is generally a just place. Good things happen to good people. Bad things happen to bad people. The fact of the matter is, if I did nothing wrong, that will come out. Justice will figure that out. And the second interesting phenomenon in psychology that I think is informative is what is called the illusion of transparency. People believe that their truths telling and their lies are transparent. People believe that when they utter the truth, others will believe them, and that when they lie, others will figure that out. And that illusion of transparency, gives comfort to the person who did nothing wrong. So when you hear the wrongfully convicted talk
现在，我们知道了这一点。心理学中有关于对公正世界信仰的研究。人们倾向于认为世界总体上是一个公正的地方。好人有好报，坏人有恶报。事实是，如果我没有做错任何事，真相就会大白，正义会弄清楚的。我认为具有启发意义的心理学中的第二个有趣现象被称为“透明度错觉”。人们相信他们的说实话和说谎是透明的。人们相信当他们说真话时别人会相信他们，而当他们撒谎时别人会看出来。这种透明度错觉给那些没有做错事的人带来了安慰。因此，当你听到被冤枉的人谈论
about why did you waive your rights, and in fact, in some cases they explain the reason I gave in and confessed was I figured, you know what, they'll proceed with their investigation, and in the end they'll see I did nothing wrong. Now, this gets to, I think, a very important point that I did not see coming until I had conversations with some of these false confessors. And it is a concept that I have gone on to call the phenomenology of innocence. An innocent person, you would think that the thing that protects an innocent person is his or her knowledge of his innocence, right? I'll be damned if I'm going to confess to something I know I didn't do. However, innocent people sometimes confess after hours of interrogation because they're led to believe that there is additional evidence
他们为什么要放弃权利时，事实上，在某些情况下他们解释说，我之所以妥协并招供，是因为我想，你知道吗，他们会继续调查，最终他们会看到我没有做错任何事。现在，这触及了我认为非常重要的一点，在我与其中一些虚假供述者交谈之前，我没有预料到这一点。这是一个我后来称之为“清白现象学”的概念。对于一个无辜的人，你可能会认为保护无辜者的是他或她对自己清白的了解，对吧？我绝不会承认一件我知道我没有做过的事情。然而，无辜的人有时在经过数小时的审讯后会招供，因为他们被引导相信有更多的证据
coming. And when they're led to believe that there's additional evidence coming, that belief, in becomes a promise of future exoneration, which paradoxly makes it easier to confess. So a number of innocent people have confessed to get out of a bad situation, believing when the police do the rest of their investigation, they'll see this wasn't me. So in a funny way, innocence can be your own enemy in that situation. And that is the same phenomenon, the same explanation as to why innocent people waive their rights. They'll look you're right in the eye and say, well, I didn't need a lawyer. I didn't do anything wrong.
即将出现。当他们被引导相信有更多的证据即将到来时，这种信念就变成了未来洗清罪名的承诺，这反而使招供变得更容易了。因此，许多无辜的人为了摆脱糟糕的处境而招供，他们相信当警察完成其余的调查时，他们会发现这不是我干的。所以从某种滑稽的角度来看，在这种情况下，清白会成为你自己的敌人。这就是为什么无辜的人会放弃他们的权利的同一种现象、同一种解释。他们会直视你的眼睛说：“嗯，我不需要律师，我又没做错什么。”
I think it's interesting that you're studying this and you were telling me this before we actually started recording, but you think it's important for a psychologist to be out there and making people aware of this kind of information. It's very important. You know, the psychology underlying false confessions is basic. We have a wealth of studies that we've done in laboratories and field settings, surveys and whatnot from the 1980s forward. All of it has been summarized in a white paper that APA Division 41 has produced. All of it is summarized in now seven amicus briefs that the APA has submitted to various state courts. But in a sense, we almost didn't need that literature to understand the underlying psychology.
我觉得很有趣的是你在研究这个，你实际上在我们开始录音之前就告诉我了，你认为心理学家走出去让人们了解这类信息是很重要的。这非常重要。你知道，虚假供述背后的心理学是基础性的。我们有大量自20世纪80年代以来在实验室和实地环境中进行的研究、调查等成果。所有这些都总结在APA（美国心理学协会）第41分部制作的一份白皮书中。所有这些都总结在APA向各州法院提交的七份法庭之友简报中。但在某种程度上，我们几乎不需要这些文献来理解背后的心理学。
It is so basic. If you understand the principles of reinforcement, if you understand the way Skinner used to shape rats in a Skinner, box, if you understand the reward contingencies that affect people's decision-making, if you remember back to Milgram's obedience experiments where people were under pressure step by step increasingly to violate their conscience, all of that is directly relevant to what happens in an interrogation room. And so psychologists, I think, are uniquely poised to help in these matters. And the reason I think raising public awareness is important. I have spent, and others have spent a lot of years trying to reform the system from the top
这非常基础。如果你理解强化原则，如果你理解斯金纳过去如何在斯金纳箱里塑造老鼠，如果你理解影响人们决策的奖赏相依性，如果你回想起米尔格拉姆的服从实验，当时人们在压力下一步步地违背自己的良心，所有这些都与审讯室里发生的事情直接相关。因此，我认为心理学家在协助处理这些事情方面具有独特的优势。我认为提高公众意识很重要的原因在于：我和其他人花了很多年试图从上到下改革这个体系
down, trying to, we speak to state legislators, we speak to state innocence commissions, we talk to groups of judges, we try to get the laws changed from the top down. And that has been somewhat successful. But what has become apparent to me, and it's become apparent in some very high-profile cases, like the Central Park 5, like Brendan Dassey's situation. What has become apparent is that another way to manage this, another way to exert our influence and, I think, help to reform a broken system,
试图与州议员对话，与州冤案委员会对话，与法官群体对话，试图自上而下地改变法律。这在一定程度上取得了成功。但对我来说显而易见的是，并且在一些备受瞩目的案件中也变得显而易见，比如中央公园五人组案，比如布伦丹·达西的境况。显而易见的是，解决这个问题的另一种方法，施加我们影响力的另一种方法，以及我认为有助于改革一个破碎体系的方法，
is to get involved in raising public awareness. I think, again, the making a murderer documentary tells me a lot. Here's a case where 16-year-old Brendan Dassey, 10 years ago, gives a confession. Now, mind you, the jury got to see the tape or parts of the tape of that interrogation, but they didn't get to hear from an expert explaining that tape. And so he gets convicted. Appeals within the state are exhausted. Everything looks like he's going to spend the next 25 years to life in prison. Then in December of 2015, the documentary is aired. There is a public outcry. 20 million people watched the documentary in the first month or so. and there is outrage over the treatment of Brendan Dassey and his confession.
就是参与提高公众意识。我认为，“制造杀人犯”这部纪录片再次说明了很多问题。这是一个10年前16岁的布伦丹·达西做出虚假供述的案件。现在请注意，陪审团看到了那次审讯的录像带或部分录像带，但他们没有听到专家的解释。因此他被定罪了。州内的上诉已经用尽。一切迹象表明他将在监狱里度过接下来的25年至无期徒刑。然后，在2015年12月，这部纪录片播出了。公众哗然。在头一个月左右的时间里，有2000万人观看了这部纪录片，人们对布伦丹·达西的遭遇及其供述感到愤怒。
Within six months, a federal judge overturned his conviction, arguing that the confession was coerced. That judge had his ruling appealed, and then a three-judge federal panel affirmed that ruling. Now, Dassey, at the moment we are speaking right now, is still incarcerated in Wisconsin because the prosecutor's office has appealed those federal decisions and wants to go back and retry him and has argued that he should remain incarcerated to that point. But the fact of the matter is DASI wasn't going anywhere until public awareness was raised. That is another way in which we can make important change. And I don't know that there's another profession as uniquely poised as psychology.
在六个月内，一名联邦法官推翻了他的定罪，认为该供述是受到胁迫的。该法官的裁决遭到上诉，随后由一个三名法官组成的联邦合议庭维持了该裁决。目前，在我们谈话的当下，达西仍然被关押在威斯康星州，因为检方对这些联邦裁决提出了上诉，并希望回去重新审判他，并主张他在那之前应该继续被关押。但事实是，如果公众意识没有被唤醒，达西哪儿也去不了。这是我们能够带来重要改变的另一种方式。而且我不知道还有哪个职业能像心理学这样具有独特的优势。
And you know what? If we don't step in to inform the public about what's happening, somebody else will. Phil Vett Void, who is less expert and less informed. Well, Dr. Kasten, thank you so much for being here today. It's been really interesting here. Pleasure. Thanks for listening. If you would like more information on the topics we discussed
你知道吗？如果我们不介入向公众通报正在发生的事情，其他人就会这么做。菲尔·韦特·沃伊德，他就不那么专业，也不那么知情。好的，卡斯滕博士，非常感谢您今天来到这里。听您分享真的非常有趣。我的荣幸。感谢收听。如果您想了解更多关于我们讨论的话题的信息
or if you would like to hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者想收听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。这里是由美国心理学协会制作的“心理学对话”，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。